bon les chéris d'ailleurs en parlant des
écolos tiens vous avez vu qu'ils sont
récidivés hier au Pont de Sèvres ils ont
aussi livré hier soir à côté de nos
studios sur le pont de Sèvres une
nouvelle fois les automobilistes se sont
énervés regardez
[Musique]
je dois passer s'il vous plaît je suis
enceinte ou chez vous
et là vous êtes ensemble
[Applaudissements]
40 minutes la circulation bloquée et le
message passe de jour en jour les gens
vont se pas du tout au contraire
les gens les gens disent tous que c'est
des emmerdeurs regarde Raymond toi tu as
eu quoi toi aujourd'hui moi non là moi
j'ai pris un peu cher sur les raisons
mais c'est pas grave je m'en souviens
pas c'est pas grave
c'était pas le bon message ils
envoyaient pas le bon message et que
c'était dangereux pour la pour leur
sécurité de se mettre au milieu de la
route comme ça il y en a un qui a failli
dégoupiller parce que il voulait aller
chercher sa petite à la maternelle c'est
pas comme ça qu'on va régler le problème
hier ils sont venus moi je pense pas que
ce soit comme ça en bloquant les gens il
y avait une dame enceinte voilà c'est
pas que c'est pas comme ça je pense que
ça pollue plus qu'autre chose et qui met
des gens en danger dans la circulation
tu te fais défoncer aujourd'hui ouais
mais moi je m'en fous moi je bloque ce
que tu m'as envoyé j'ai des gars au cul
là
j'ai des écoles au cul
je m'en fous c'était marrant qu'est-ce
qu'ils t'ont dit c'est marrant bah ils
m'ont dit que j'avais rien compris bon
après ils ont dit que des vérités que
j'avais un cul que j'étais concombre
comme mes pieds c'est que des vérités
tout ça je suis au courant moi je ne
sais déjà mais c'est vrai que c'est
beaucoup d'insultes beaucoup de gens qui
étaient d'accord parce que depuis le
temps que tu es là tu dis tu as dit j'ai
dit des choses qu'on parle plus aux gens
ou que j'ai dit maladroitement je me
suis jamais fait autant défoncer que par
les écoles et encore il y a 100 mine de
rien non mais c'est vrai raison sur le
fond mais là
il vaut mieux il vaut mieux qu'ils voilà
qui s'attaque aux institutions non mais
là la bloqué les routes ça sert à rien
encore ils ont bloqué je veux dire ça va
mal se terminer
c'est un mec vraiment vénère qui qui va
ça va choquer
ça et je leur ai dit vous allez voir ça
il va y avoir il y aura c'est ça qui
c'est ils oublient qu'il y a des gens
qui ont beaucoup de problèmes qui a des
gens qui sont un peu à bout de nerf qui
sont à cran tu vas t'asseoir devant la
voiture d'un mec le mec il va voir rouge
il va passer la première il va lui
rouler dessus il faut on dirait qu'ils
ont pas pensé à ça et je voudrais
pousser un autre petit coup de gueule
sur la police parce que si tu fais des
trucs comme ça ça s'appelle quoi ça
c'est rebellion sur c'est c'est sur la
voie publique
parce que il y a certains endroits quand
la police elle t'arrête et qu'elle
t'envoie sur le trottoir si tu retournes
il te plaque au sol ils te mettent les
menottes et il te maltraite je les ai
trouvés super gentil quand même avec eux
peut-être que c'est filmé j'ai vu des
interventions sur moi
je suis désolé
tu dois tu dois les déplacer tu peux pas
tu peux pas aller malmener je suis
désolé
c'est qu'avec le discours qu'on a eu
l'idée jeune d'hier ils ont l'impression
de devoir faire des choses comme ça pour
être invité sur les plateaux et du coup
ils étaient contents ils disent oui mais
on est obligé parce que quand on fait
des trucs pacifistes et ben là on est
pas invité on n'est pas écouté
c'est une réalité sauf que le souci
c'est que l'on les invite tellement les
déteste et tellement on leur dit vous
êtes nuls et c'est pas ça qu'il faut
faire donc si tu les invites et qu'on se
dit ah ouais mais en fait on a envie
d'être avec vous parce que vous avez
raison l'écologie c'est important et moi
j'ai envie d'être avec eux mais quand il
faut un truc comme ça mais on pas envie
d'être avec eux donc en fait ils sont
invités pas pour les bonnes raisons il
est là le problème donc c'est pas
chef
[Rires]
pourquoi cette petite pique non j'ai pas
voulu te déranger il y a des gens qui
parlentir
un vrai harcèlement des automobilistes
tout le monde focalise sur eux alors
qu'ils viennent d'avoir la grève des
raffineries les problèmes des sens il y
a des taxes il y a le les 110 km/h au
lieu des 130 enfin c'est constamment sur
les automobilistes alors qu'en fait le
problème n'est pas là en France et ces
écolos moi je veux bien qu'ils essayent
d'éveiller à leur combat mais il parle
jamais des choses importantes et il
focalise encore sur le CO2 alors qu'il y
a plein d'autres choses
les pesticides l'acidification des
océans la microbiologie des sols la
pauvrissement des sols etc c'est des
gros problèmes et en fait je les trouve
assez hypocrite parce qu'il s'attaque
qu'à des petits sujets comme ça fermez
votre boîte Wi-Fi ou des éco-gestes au
lieu de de s'attaquer à des problèmes
peut-être plus polémiques sur les la
politique internationale comme tu étais
pas là hier sur ce sujet qu'est ce que
tu en penses toi est-ce que tu veux dire
le problème c'est une parole
intelligente alors le problème
excuse-moi ça va toi sinon le melon
de manière intelligente le débat
bébé c'est qu'en France le problème
c'est qu'on crée cette info doux on
traite les causes avant les conséquences
exemple voilà on s'occupe de l'écologie
en France mais à Paris par exemple mais
on ne met pas plus de métro on ne
climatise pas les métros on met pas plus
de bus mais on enlève les voitures donc
voilà il y a plus de voitures mais il y
a rien pour eux voilà c'est idem
pourtant et c'est toujours le même
problème à chaque fois c'est la cause et
pas la conséquence et voilà pourquoi on
est en une telle merde et ça c'est
[Musique]
[Rires]
insupportable quand je vois cette femme
qui est enceinte qui dit laissez-moi
passer on a envie de dire oui laisser la
passer et puis donc c'est très compliqué
j'aimerais que ça aille mieux j'ai un
peu l'impression d'avoir vécu une
meilleure période que celle
d'aujourd'hui voilà et franchement si on
peut s'arranger pour bien vivre ensemble
ce serait bien ce serait vraiment bien
c'est le passé